And I'm sympathetic
to your struggle, truly.
But there's a protocol
to visiting a patient
like Victor.
You have to put in
a request.
And then you have to undergo
a screening process,
at which point
the board
will make a decision.
I can see
you're disappointed.
But I'm more than happy
to give you a tour
of our facility?
Perhaps, you can even speak
to some patients
in our low-security wing.
And we'd,
we would love that.
It's just that our thesis
is due next month.
Then you're out of time.
Who's fault is that?
Ours. Absolutely.
-And I do apologise--
-Don't apologise, Ruth.
Screw that!
The fact of the matter is
we did put in a request
months ago and were denied.
And then we reapplied
and were denied again.
And coming here,
was our last-ditch effort
to save our thesis,
and I really,
I can't breathe
in this thing.
Well, Rose, maybe
you'd like to go outside
and get some air?
Maybe I should, Ruth.
Because I'm starting
to think this whole thing
is a colossal mistake.
I'm breaking out in a rash,
my boobs hurt,
and I'll tell you the truth,
Anthony,
may I call you Anthony?
These aren't actually
my clothes.
I borrowed them
because I wanted you
to take us seriously,
because nobody takes girls
seriously in this field.
They just don't.
We don't look the part,
or whatever,
but can I tell you a story?
1978, I was at summer camp,
and my counsellor, Drew,
told me
and everyone in cabin C
the true story of
the Victor Creel massacre.
And little Petey McHugh,
you know Petey, right, Ruth?
-Of course.
-Yeah.
Little Petey McHugh
started sobbing
right there on the spot.
Full on hyperventilating
and all the other campers,
they couldn't sleep
for weeks.
And I couldn't sleep either,
but not 'cause I was scared,
because I was obsessed
with the question:
what would drive
a human being
to commit
such unimaginable acts.
Other kids,
they wanted to be
astronauts,
basketball players,
rockstars,
but I wanted to be you.
I wanted to be you,
so forgive me if I'll now
try anything in my power,
including wearing
this ridiculous outfit,
if I might get the chance
to speak to the man
that ignited my passion
and learn a little bit more
about how his twisted,
but let's face it,
totally fascinating mind,
works.
So, yes, we don't have
the "official" paperwork,
but don't tell me
that crybaby Petey McHugh
wouldn't have gotten
an audience with Victor
in a matter of moments
if he'd asked politely
'cause you and I both know
that he would!
So… ten minutes with Victor.
Is all I ask.
I'm back in thirty.
We did it!